Shawn is with us in Huntsville hey Shawn
thanks for calling the Dave Ramsey show
hi Dave how are you doing thanks for
taking my call
sure man so I'm gonna do the same thing
with you how old are you I'm 51 okay and
what's your net worth sir
about 1.5 million okay cool and what's
that invested in mostly a mutual fund
some in some stocks just a couple of
stocks and cash how'd you do that
how'd you get a million and a half
dollars at 51 yes slow and steady slow
and steady investing strategy we made
sure that we made statements of priority
every month to you know make sure we
save that every paycheck lives way below
our means all the time actually and so
we you know we you know and just now
works to kind of get in on the budget
and so we can kind of plan that the
second phase of our life did you uh did
you inherit money
no no anybody gonna start out with money
then Denisov no I I started off
you know middle class middle class
parents I joined the military out of
high school spend 26 years in the army
and through that process and thankfully
I have a very very supportive wife and
family that you know that we we kind of
live the lifestyle that helped us to get
to where we are today so you did the
serving in the military yes yes sir and
did you graduate from college I did yeah
I went through college yeah while I was
on active duty in the military Korean
watch this degree I'm sorry a degree in
what Business Administration what was
your GPA about a 3.7 yeah it's about
average okay yep yeah very very few
millionaires have a 4.0 by the way yeah
the average is about the average is
about 3.1 I forgot to ask that of the
others but that's very interesting so
what was your income average through
your working lifetime estimate about
$70,000 what was the high the high is
about 220 how many new cars have you
bought I bought one in 1994 and I turn
around and sold it two months later
because I hated having
so your anti debt anti debt yet at all
today yes sir just a mortgage okay a
little bit on your mortgage alright and
well tell me about your generosity well
that's an area that my wife and I you
know now that we reach this milestone
we're kind of focusing on that you know
you say in maybe step seven you know you
know live and give like like no one else
and so that's an area now that we were
getting to focus on and and she's always
been very generous and I tip my hat to
her and so now the other team were
coming together to figure out how we can
you know better live and in that
philosophy and so are you are you
telling me in the 1.5 million that the
mutual funds are there that basically
working in the military and your wife
working or not working that you guys
saved money into mutual funds into 401ks
and that kind of stuff every month for
most of your life and you have 1.5
million dollars or you tell me that's
how it happened that's out happened a
man thank you for the call I'm proud of
you
you're the American dream I'm honored to
talk to you sir and thank you for your
service to this country
see you can be in the military and be a
millionaire
this is a study of millionaires you need
to be real quiet and keep your opinions
to yourself and listen you be in school
you